it's magic man you're just gonna walk
away from magic like anybody can [ __ ]
do magic
[ __ ] magic hey everybody i'm the
magician mirage why would i call myself
mr h rappers and stuff they take the
vowels out
i think they're [ __ ] how can you not
believe in magic you wake up in the
morning you walk to the bathroom
something comes out of your body that's
magic you go to a store
you are looking for something
it's not there
it disappeared that would mean that
someone maybe like came in and bought it
or it's magic mirage i know you're
looking now at an athletic body
but i was not a popular kid in school if
you can believe that some times people
made my lunch money disappear
so i thought when i grew up i'm gonna
make things disappear mirage
these guys are pretending like close-up
magic is hard it's the easiest kind let
me show you closer
closer see these cards closer closer
closer
not cards anymore see that get close
enough nobody can see what your hands
are doing mirage
i have a very
ambitious goal making the statue of
liberty disappear whatever making a boat
disappear
whatever
i'm gonna make an entire
city disappear
las vegas is gonna disappear you wanna
know how i'm gonna do it yes i can't
tell you magician never spills his
tricks the thing is i'm just going to
get everybody out first so that's the
tricky part mirage i'll pick a card oh
this one
is that your card wait a second did that
work
it did work mirage
as a magician there's no shortage
of women but the type of woman who's
into a magician is
probably a little different than what
you're used to
she probably brings snacks in her purse
she definitely has
one or two
cats per room at her house she's
probably over the age of 40. her hands
probably either smell like cigarettes or
cheetos mirage
humor's really important knock knock
who's there interrupting cow
kills every time i've heard that before
i think i don't think so i definitely
made that one up you want the crowd
laughing because when they're laughing
you know what they're not staring at
is these beautiful little babies right
here this is where the magic happens
and it's important to let them know when
they're supposed to laugh i just make a
rim shot noise
after every joke
see
can i ask the question sure
but why are you doing
does it look like i need a backup plan
take a look at this card
you memorize it
is that your card
yeah but you didn't
is it your card yeah do i need a backup
plan i need to get on that show i need
to get in front of howie mandel they
keep letting me audition if i wasn't
good enough would they that may audition
what does that mean open auditions well
like there's not like a barrier to entry
they got to filter out the people who
aren't talented enough to be on the show
did you audition
no okay well then it's not open is it if
it was open auditions wouldn't everybody
do it doesn't everybody want to be on
america's got talent hey you want to see
some magic do you mind if i get you on
camera pick a car at any car short
camera
is that your card yeah that's it you
know what we call that what magic that's
good man hey i got somewhere to beat
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]